[Musique]
cette année pour la première fois les
revenus de musiciennes ont dépassé les
revenus professeur de piano
si je m'appelle laurent cjr dont je suis
chanteuse pour le groupe
le couleur et musicienne professeur de
piano
si on regarde les chiffres de l'idée à
un membre actif gagnent en moyenne
autour de 21 mille dollars par année
donc qu'est ce que tu peux nous dire si
tu t'es tu légèrement au dessus ou en
dessous
moi si j'avais juste un groupe de
musique je pourrais pas vivre comme je
le souhaite donc là j'enseigne le piano
si à côté j'ai des confrères de studio
de différents artistes qui me demande de
faire des coeurs pour une chanson j'ai
beaucoup de collaborations aussi donc
des artistes qui me demande d'écrire des
paroles ou se fait tout ça ensemble mis
ensemble ça fait que j'ai un revenu
comme ses supérieurs un petit peu à la
moyenne 17 c'est que de dire dans
certaines blanche ma mère elle est
pianiste classique
donc je pense que j'ai commencé à lire
la musique avant même de savoir à lire
le donc à trois quatre ans j'ai commencé
des cours de piano donc 25 ans j'ai
commencé un gros porc
[Musique]
pas vraiment été sa matrice cure des
patates et les femmes
[Musique]
ton père est d'origine vietnamienne de
surcroît médecins ce qui est des
déshérités presque
non mais là ça va ça va mieux on eu des
grosses discussions
c'est sûr que pour la communauté les
vietnamiens est important aussi d'avoir
des métiers qui sont qui est même
d'argent pour entretenir la famille j'ai
une fait j'ai un appartement tissage une
moto tout va bien qui montre qu'on
jouait dans la musique ebuddy incognita
gagner et ont sonné âgées venues récit
toi merci
part de cette chanson la femme alors
qu'elle ment 4 millions de bj ou sur
youtube et beaucoup le 4 millions on
reçoit chalon 2 dollars payne dollars
par trimestre
si on regarde au ministère de la culture
en dix ans les budgets ont quand même
augmenté d'environ 20% ministère de la
culture de n'empêche présentement est ce
que vous êtes trop nombreux à vous
partager cet art là il ya un problème
dans la disposition de la terre qui
prouve que les gros artistes ont
beaucoup beaucoup de subventions qui
pourraient peut-être être attribuée aux
plus petits j'ai vraiment une surprise
n'est sûr que c'est vraiment qu'elle
doit deuxième même parfaitement
on coupe tous les programmes de musique
on leur laisse comme la flûte à bec qui
salissent comme vraiment un souvenir
amer en nous est offert comme ça avenue
dollard cette chance-là aux jeunes de
toute chasse puis choisir osaka est une
carrière
[Musique]